[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es einen richtig leckeren
kuchen ich werde nämlich die klassische
philadelphia torte machen die aber ein
bisschen aufpeppen
ich habe hier eine version mit einem no
big boden mit der philadelphia creme und
innen habe ich noch eine himbeere frucht
einlage und gleich beim anrichten kommt
noch diese leckere maracuja soße trügen
die sind wirklich super lecker aus und
riecht auch total gut ich starte jetzt
zuerst einmal mit der nebenbei folgt ein
lager die muss ich nämlich einfrieren
damit diese weiter verwenden kann und
dafür benutze ich folgende zutaten 250
gramm himbeeren ivan tiefgefroren die
habe ich jetzt auftauen lassen
100 milliliter wasser und fünf gramm ag
für die frucht einlage gebe ich jetzt
alle zutaten in einen topf denn wenn man
ackermann muss das ganze gekocht werden
damit das engagement tina auch wirken
kann
ich hab jetzt tiefgefrorene himbeeren
genommen und die an braucht hauen lassen
ihr könnt aber auch frische nehmen wenn
gerade saison ist es kommt das ag3 mit
dem wasser und dann wird alles kurz
verrührt und ich lasse die masse
aufkochen und dann zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen
jetzt kann ich die himbeer masse vom
herd herunterziehen
und ich lasse jetzt ganz kurz abkühlen
die wird jetzt nämlich eingefüllt in
diesen tortenring den habe ich schon auf
20 cm durchmesser eingestellt und
einfach auf den torten retter gelegt so
kann ich die frucht maße nämlich hier
einführen und dann einfrieren und habe
später eine richtig tolle platte das
ganze lasse ich jetzt nur kurz abkühlen
weil sie jetzt einfach noch sehr flüssig
ist und wer möchte kann die masse noch
durch ein haarsieb streichen und die
kerne weg aber ich finde auch mal ganz
schön wenn die kerne dabei sind und
während die masse dann im gefrierschrank
für etwa eine stunde abkühlt kann ich
schon mal den keks boden zu bereiten und
dafür verwende ich diese zutaten für den
boden brauche ich 125 gramm butter 150
gramm butterkekse und wer möchte kann
auf 50 gramm gehobelte oder charakter
man bilder zu geben
für den norden gebe ich jetzt zuerst die
butter in einen kleinen topf von lastig
schmelzen und nowak boden finde ich
immer genial weil sie super schnell
hergestellt sind und vor allem kann man
sie individuell abwandeln ich gebe es
zum beispiel gleich noch zu den basics
zutaten ein bisschen zitronenschalen
abrieb dazu und wenn es aber die zeit
nutzen um jetzt erstmal die kekse zu
verkleinern
jetzt kommen die keks brüssel mit seiner
mutter die kann ich jetzt vom herd
herunternehmen und werden ganz kurz ein
gerührt hier kommen jetzt noch den
mandeln mit rein
die sorgen für eine richtig schöne und
biss und wer möchte kann das ganze dann
mit der zitronenschale aufpeppen
da müsst ihr unbedingt darauf achten
dass es eine unbehandelte zitrone
[Musik]
und diese lecker duftende masse werdet
in meinem parkring eingefüllt wird aber
nicht gebacken
den habe ich auf 26 cm durchmesser
eingestellt darunter liegt ein
backpapier und ein topmanager
wer möchte kann das backpapier auch
gerne schneiden dann stört das den
kühlschrank eigentlich nicht dafür falls
ich es immer ganz gerne zu einem großen
dreieck mir die spitze hier in die mitte
ungefähr und schneit mit der schere
einmal aus noch um
jetzt hier einfach einfüllen und dann
schön platt drücken
und jetzt verdichtet den boden einfach
mit einem glas so wieder schön fest und
da kann ich den noten einfach in den
kühlschrank stellen für etwa eine halbe
stunde
[Musik]
die frucht einlage ist gefroren der
boden ist abgekühlt und jetzt kümmere
ich mich um die leckere philadelphia
creme dies sogar schnell zubereitet und
ihr braucht auch nur ganz wenige zutaten
für die philadelphia tränen verwende ich
525 gramm philadelphia in doppel ram
stufe 300 gramm sahne etwas vanille
extrakt eine unbehandelte zitrone 100
gramm puderzucker und etwa 6
telefonapparat die creme ist jetzt auch
ganz schnell hergestellt dafür nehmen
die jetzt einfach den frischkäse und er
passt wirklich perfekt zu allen noweck
torten dann macht das ganze wunderbar
cremig und ich finde philadelphia macht
einfach den besten geschmack
hier kommen jetzt noch die übrigen
zutaten mit rein an so dass man ihr
extrakt dann etwas zitronenschale april
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt noch der puderzucker
mit rein
die sahne und das dann apart und jetzt
kann ich das creme schön glatt rühren
[Musik]
unter mir die creme richtig lecker wird
kommt noch der zitronensaft reiben
[Musik]
jetzt wird die torte gefüllt dafür nehme
ich jetzt die frucht einlage und löste
einmal aus dem ring heraus
[Musik]
und jetzt einfach richtig schön hier mit
reinlegen und hier kommt jetzt die
leckere creme drüber
[Musik]
der rest auf dem feld da ist für mich
die torte darf in den kühlschrank darf
ich doch ausruhen und in der zeit knapp
ich mir mal die maracuja vor 45 maracuja
die sind richtig schön reif das erkennt
man an der schale die ist nämlich so ein
bisschen schrumpelig und da kann man
jetzt einfach die maracuja halbieren und
das innere herr auslöffeln am besten
direkt in einen topf
[Musik]
und dieses fruchtpüree könnt ihr jetzt
zum beispiel mit etwas zucker süßen
probiert es einfach mal vorher manchmal
sind sie etwas süßer manchmal
säuerlicher und zum binden nehme ich
jetzt wieder aber ihr könnt auch zum
beispiel speisestärke verwenden
jetzt kann ich das fruchtpüree aufkochen
und wieder mindestens zwei minuten
sprudelnd kochen lassen und jetzt kann
ich das furchtbar durch ein sieb
streichen so kann ich die kerne
entfernen und dann einfach abkühlen
lassen und später die torte damit
dekorieren
[Musik]
nach der kühl seit wird die torte dann
aus dem tortenring herausgelöst und das
geht am besten mit einem backform messer
jetzt setze ich hier noch die himbeeren
drauf und der maracuja kurs der kommt
jetzt erst auf die fertigen stückchen
dann sieht nämlich der anschnitt richtig
schön aus und so kann ich das jedem ob
den teller geben also jetzt können wir
anschneiden und ich finde die
überraschung das ist immer noch echt
diese frucht einlage in der mitte da
recht meistens keiner damit
[Musik]
guckt man sieht das nicht schön aus
richtig hübsch und jetzt kommt da noch
deckel drauf die maracuja so müssen
[Musik]
und die ist echt super lecker dies total
schnell hergestellt und ich find's
einfach perfekt weil man bei dieser
kühlschrank torte einfach keinen
backofen benötigt also die kann wirklich
jeder zu bereiten
ganz alleine zu hause ganz einfach ohne
werkzeug und ohne viele zutaten dann
könnt ihr schon probieren und die creme
passt wirklich perfekt zu den himbeeren
da hat man eine leichte säure mit dabei
die frucht aus dem maracuja echt gut ich
glaube das wird ab sofort meine
lieblings kühlschrank torte und ich
glaube eure wird wahrscheinlich auch
deswegen weil sie dieses rezept nach
machen möchtet dann schaut auf meinem
blog vorbei auf kellys blog.de da steht
alles noch mal ganz genau ich würde mich
wahnsinnig darüber freuen wenn ihr auch
diese torte nach macht nicht nach back
denn das ist ein objekt orte dann könnt
ihr mich gerne auch instagram oder auf
facebook markieren
ich schaue mir eure bilder an und freue
mich darüber also viel spaß beim
zubereiten und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]